is your latest fling just pretending
he's left wing is your date pretending
to be woke just to get a quick poke the
latest dating trend is called woke
fishing where people pretend to be
progressive in order to lure potential
partners yikes lying about being over
five foot five is one thing but that is
really terrible
somebody changed that joke
dating expert alex miller brook told the
daily mail that singles can protect
themselves by either asking their dates
to elaborate on their views on issues
like feminism and climate change or by
waiting to share their views on those
issues so dates can't use them to
manipulate you
which sounds like a fun evening
or you could meet them at a hip downtown
cafe then see if they smash the windows
my idea when you're with a date turn on
don lemon tonight if they don't
immediately run from the room screaming
and throwing up then you probably found
someone who will throw vegan burritos at
cops with you
that was tremendous all right
[Laughter]
wow
mailing it in today people
michelle yes
this is not new i mean woke fishing is
what all guys did
to pretend that they cared about
you were talking about when we really
didn't uh go to an animal right
animal rights concerts climate change uh
rallies in the 80s and 90s this is what
guys did hey let's go to sproul plaza
and protest apartheid because there's
some hot chicks down there exactly no
question you know what's a better way to
get a really
solid gal
just sit somewhere with a puppy yeah and
the women will come flocking to you
that's worse but you know what well i
guess i mean because what if you're a
homicidal maniac oh that's a psychopath
but you have a puppy take that back i
did not give that tip
you're saying i should go to a rally a
political rally with a puppy
don't take a puppy to a political rally
but you're right i mean aren't we always
manipulating you know to try to
especially if it's for a quick poke as
you said anyone cares yeah no cares it's
like it's just lie away martha um you
know i don't know what to ask you i'm
afraid
you know what i'm a big proponent of
people meeting in person at bars i met
my husband at a bar you know it's like
the old-fashioned way with a bunch of
friends and you just i don't remember us
talking about feminism like when we
first met to get to know each other but
i guess that's the way things happen
online and you know then they they the
conversation goes on and on and on
before they actually meet each other so
i don't know i don't i don't recommend
it i recommend meeting people in person
you know kat when you were dating were
you always suspicious of a guy trying to
act deep because that was the thing that
guys would always try to do like
memorize maybe like a quote or some poem
and they'd come up to you at a bar and
they would like read a poem to you i
used to see that on blind date a lot
happened to me with this one guy now
he's dead
and you know what somehow i don't think
that was a joke no of course not no no
yeah no rest in peace um but it was a
song lyric but yeah he is dead now yes
um
what
i didn't kill him
glad he cleared that
uh but yeah but it's also like i think
the key is
uh just don't care if they like you or
not what do you care if someone likes
you or not yeah there's seven billion
people there's so many people and it's
like so like it's like it's difficult to
find a man who wants to have sex with
you so like you just be yourself yeah
that is true why do you yeah what you
you think
well i can only speak from the guy side
um and not everyone wants to have sex
with us yes so i have
i have been a lot of things i've been an
astronomer
poet
a mechanic uh i was fat joe the wrapper
one night when i was like 18 in a club
somebody asked me if i was fat joe i was
like yeah sure i am um
i've worn many hats to get
not bad ass i don't know how to put it
but
that's what guys do we lie the only
thing we're not good at is getting out
of the lie and we end up in marriages
where we carry the lie and we just keep
going and going and
never not knowing the difference between
a milky way in the sky or a bar but if
you're good at that's what guys do man
that's that's our peacocking you know we
don't have cool feathers and colors so
we have to a lot yeah the only thing is
though the good thing about i think it's
a smart move to go to political events
because then the conversations already
started
you don't have to you could just like
walk up to somebody oh what's going on
over here i'm going to say this greg and
it's probably going to be the last thing
i say here's the thing most of the time
they don't
you don't have to say much because they
never stopped talking yeah all you
really wait a minute wait a minute
disagree you say yeah astronomy they're
going to go mm-hmm yeah right oh that's
are you saying they as in the women i
can't really commit to that yes or no
they just talk all the time
and i respect you for that thank you yes
but them chicks don't shut up oh my god
a sexist would say
and we all like sexist around
no
get that get your sexist butt out of
here tell
that was a great save definitely not
going to add this to the tape i've been
compiling
don't go away we'll be right back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else